they bring in Andrew Brandt columnist at
mm QB the former Packers executive
former agents what do you think of what
we're saying for the Miami Dolphins in
what they should do always good to be
with you Dan you know I look at these
two quarterbacks as one too the more
interesting business of football stories
of the year
Fitzpatrick's a business of Football
Hall of Famer I mean he keeps making
money he keeps getting multiple millions
from these teams that just want him as a
stopgap yet he you know he finds a way
and Josh Rosen gets picked number ten in
the draft gets the huge bonus from
Arizona gets millions and millions from
them and they don't even use them after
a year so I just think this is always
the dilemma so Josh Rosen's like a
first-round pick even though he's a year
removed and do you have the stopgap or
do you not last year Baker Mayfield sits
behind Tyrod Taylor Josh McCown a head
of Sam Donald Lamar Jackson behind Joe
Flacco all these guys are just kind of
waiting so this is the question you're
just debating why wait why wait because
the guys kind of growing pains at some
point yeah so get rid of them
rid of the growing pains as soon as
possible I don't understand the signing
of these ten to fifteen million dollars
stopgaps every year I'll get your
thoughts on a zekiel Elliott and if you
are his agent
what would your leverage be I don't know
if you saw Bucky Brooks's article his
list of the top quarterbacks five
quarterbacks going into this season but
Aaron Rodgers was not on the top five
list and the headline was Aaron Rodgers
is overrated what do you make of that
former Packers executive yeah the guy
was in the room drafting Aaron Rodgers
not going to get a good response out of
me I mean I think he's the most talented
quarterback in the league I just don't
you know I would put him up there with
my home's in that category I just don't
understand that
now can you can you answer this as a guy
who was and maybe you can't do it
objectively because you yeah you know
you bought into aaron rodgers and said
draft him when you were with the packers
but he's the most talented we all talk
about that that's what we always start
with with aaron rodgers he's the most
talented okay is he the best quarterback
I mean listen I'm gonna say yes I do
understand looking at the recent sample
size it wasn't good you know but again
suspending him I guess last year game
one knee injury lingers all year by the
way a game they beat the Bears I just
think that it got stale with Mike I've
talked about that before
you know I hired Mike 13 years ago 13
years with Aaron Rodgers got stale and
you could tell it in the offense nothing
against either of them no one's fault
relationships get that way so I think
we'll see a different Aaron Rodgers with
the new coach do you think that he if I
said you can have Patrick mahomes for
Aaron Rodgers this season yeah my bias
is Shawn I'll take care of this season
you take many five seasons of course I'm
taking the homes alright if you're Zeke
Elliot's agent yeah what is your
strategy here and what leveraged you
well you're hoping you're hoping that
there's a realization that as good as
they can be they could be a lot better
with Elliot they know that you're
hearing all the devaluation of running
back stories you're hearing about you
know Todd Gurley is replaced by a
journeyman and they continued seamlessly
you're hanging about seventh round
running backs coming out every year and
having thousand yard seasons you've just
got to play to the point that that's all
fine but this guy is truly special and
there aren't many and you can count them
on less than one hand and he's that guy
so with someone special all that goes
out the window and you pay him at the
top of the market now rather than
waiting until he's more situated
contract wise to do that
but he's got two years left on this deal
and so it's not even like dak Prescott
and Amari Cooper they're coming up
sooner than him and it would feel like
in the locker room
take care of the guys who were up sooner
than Zeek Elliot but can I can I give
him a contract that does give him money
extends him but it's also team friendly
yeah I think that's what's gonna happen
now everything I was just saying I'm
putting on my Packers hat my executive
Hatton's iver arguments to refute that a
couple of what you just mentioned here's
the problem not only do you have
devaluation of running backs but you
just mentioned you have star players
closer to the end of their contract and
everything you do is a team executive
everything you do is judge by the rest
of the team so you're gonna have a line
at your door if you do someone with two
years left and that's always the case
the problem for Elliot is he might do a
contract and the reason I say that is
I'm sure with Gordon and Elliot they put
out some offers and they can look at
themselves and say you know what this
guy's got two years left or option
option for Gordon and but we're we're
gonna offer something but it's not good
it's not good it's not anywhere near
what they want now if they turn that
down the team can say oh wow well we did
something we didn't want to do and you
still don't want it I just think here's
the contracts that Gordon and Elliot are
gonna get obviously guarantee this year
because they were going to play this
year guarantee next year and then it's
kind of we'll see after that no matter
how much money to get the next two years
these teams are going to guarantee
beyond 2020 it's just for running back -
just don't do that and you know Le'Veon
Bell
everything's been proven that there's
not going to be a lot of guaranteed
money socked into these running back
contracts two years max Wow and you know
what Jerry Jones is such a bad poker
player now that right this isn't Jerry
Jones from the early 90s this is
different Jerry Jones and everybody
knows you know you can say what you want
Jerry's gonna cave here at some point
would you sense that if you were Zeke's
agent it you would say to your client
hey
it's you know what he's gonna give you
what is great market value they need you
he needs to win a Super Bowl he's
desperate win a Super Bowl we're going
to get paid yeah I think Caves gonna be
an operative word listen here's what I
did then I had a few of these you know
Javon Walker and Mike McKenzie Donald
Driver in my day and there's three
things you can do one you can totally
ignore them say show up too when you
show up to you can rip up their contract
you more brand-spanking-new top of the
market deal teams don't want to do that
and sort of the middle ground is kind of
throw them some extra money that what I
call earner Bulls like some workout
money some performance incentives some
extra per game roster bonuses but bring
it up millions of dollars without you
can face your team and say head and tear
that up I'm not doing that so I think
cave in the fact that I think I'll get a
new deal but I think Elliott will
quote-unquote cave that he won't get
this top of the market major guaranteed
todd gurley forty five million plus
guarantee deal I just don't think it'll
happen but I also look at this and the
leverage the Cowboys may have is you
know what we're going to give you less
guaranteed money because look at the way
you've acted off the field off you know
yeah you know that you we're sorry we
can't give you that guaranteed money
that you think but do you think that
that is going to be used in this
situation I thought I saw a quote from
Stephen Jones talking about telling his
own kids you know everything's judged
your your facebook posts you know the
whole body of work is judged which is
kind of a subtle not so subtle hint that
yes that's part of the equation and when
I negotiated contracts I didn't hit it
over the head with a hammer to the agent
but they knew you know someone had off
the field problems someone had character
issues well-documented that affects the
whole thing just like good character
adds value to contract negotiations when
I was representing players that teams
love for their work ethic it all it all
goes in there it's all part of the mix
if we talk in a month what's the
situation in Dallas
my guess is Elliot's in with a contract
guaranteeing I 25 to 30 million over the
next two years and nothing guaranteed
after that and then DAC is DAC signed
Amari Cooper signed yeah I think
Cooper's closer you know I know Joel
Joel's at the camp these days Joel
Siegel is agent who I you know Prescott
is going to be a big deal we'll just see
where that is I can criticize the
Cowboys for this Dan and my last thing
is that you gotta stagger these I had a
when I had a quarterback a starburst I
mean you got a staggering got to get one
done last year you get you can't be
letting all these guys come at the same
time now maybe they didn't plan on
Elliot obviously but that's the problem
here what's the craziest negotiation you
ever had you know what no names
craziest well I'll give you a name oh
well I'm not gonna give you a lot of
details but the name I'd rather you
didn't give me the name but gave me all
the details well I had a player that I
was star player for us that I just could
not get to focus on his deal so I flew
to him went to his place where he shows
up every day for his lunch
he looks walks in the door looks Andrew
what the blank are you doing here I said
we got to get your deal done he said I
relax you know and play golf so I'm not
a good golfer he's a scratch golfer he
played and I tried to get it done that
day tiger the next day cotton finally
got him to focus and sage and flew down
and we signed a huge deal on a golf
course somewhere so that was Mississippi
you were in kill Mississippi I'm not
talking about that
did did the the guy you were sitting
down with playing golf did he sound
anything like this
course how to deal of course that's all
read Favre impersonation you know why I
spent three years managing [ __ ]
managing Brett and Erin who you know it
was it was you had one guy it's not you
know it's not great to walk in every day
and see your replacement sitting there
and then on the iron side it's not great
walking every day and not knowing if
you'll ever play but when did you know
that Rogers could be as good if not
better than far I'm gonna say first
practice first minicamp
I mean this guy wait you knew that he
was as good as walking around and oh my
god the guy takes the ball movement and
Donald Driver 60 yards on a rope and Ted
Thompson never ever showed emotion but I
somehow I locked eyes with him when that
happened and he gave me a look like we
just solved her future fire it did done
did people want to move Favre earlier
than what happened no but I think you
saw towards the end I think everyone saw
it was not the recruitment in Southern
Mississippi like it had been every year
it was more okay
you decide and that's when he retired
and we turned the keys over to Erin of
course and then I think in retrospect
and what we should have done it would
have been a very hard conversation but I
knew in the back of my mind he'd get the
itch again and you know maybe we should
have had the tough conversation that you
know if you want to come back just
letting you know we're turning this over
you know this this is Erin because when
he did come back as everyone knows it
was mess he was ugly and I you know I
heard Mike McCarthy telling those three
words that no one ever wants to hear
which are we've moved on and that's
tough for anyone especially such a great
player like Brett such
touch the face of the franchise for two
decades if you had one game to win
you could have rogers arf arf at their
peak okay you're killing me here that's
my job I guess I'll say Brett because
he's done you know Aaron's got more to
come so it's going to be a tougher
question obviously when we look back on
both know by the slightest of you know
one of those Tour de France finishes
there Andrew great to talk to you
hopefully I got you in trouble with
somebody and we appreciate your time
I'll be back soon girl you Dan Andrew
Brent used to be with the Packers now a
columnist for the mm QB for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]